Welcome to this deep dive.
I'm really glad you are joining us today.
We are going to be looking closely at Reza Shah Kazemi's spiritual ethos, specifically his essay on the mind of the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
It is just a remarkable piece of work.
It demands a complete reorientation of how we think.
It really does.
And the deep dive will explore why the author renders the central concept of consciousness as
intellect, never reason, and where that single profound choice leads.
Because the core principle here, the absolute center of it all is this, that which has no second.
does not enter the category of number.
I think we have to establish the crisis before we can even get to that principle though, because I mean, if you look at our modern society, we have a very specific vocabulary for praising a great mind.
We certainly do.
Think about the words we instinctively reach for.
You know, we call someone highly rational.
Or we say they are intensely logical.
Precisely.
We compliment them for being sharp in an argument.
We praise the calculating mind that can weigh claims and find the most efficient outcome.
But using that vocabulary words like rational or logical, when trying to describe how the commander of the faithful actually perceived reality, it feels fundamentally inadequate.
It feels restrictive.
It does.
It feels like you are trying to force something completely boundless into this very tight modern box.
There is a governing analogy here that captures that failure perfectly.
It is like trying to gauge the depth of an ocean with a ruler meant for a desk.
Standard 12 inch wooden ruler and you are just standing on the shore repeatedly dipping it into the surf.
Exactly.
And the real tragedy of that image is not just that the ruler is too short.
It is that reason overreaches its limits when applied to the infinite.
It is simply the wrong tool for the medium.
So if reason is that inadequate desk ruler snapping under the pressure,
What is the ocean measuring instrument?
Well, the author insists that we have to set aside the word reason entirely in this context.
We have to resurrect the classical meaning of the word intellect.
And we should be clear because modern English has sort of flattened those terms until they mean the same thing.
They really have.
He is not using intellect to mean cleverness or being good at standardized exams.
He is reaching back to the Latin intellectus, which mirrors the Greek nous.
Meaning it is not just
a machine for processing data.
No, it is a direct contemplative vision of transcendent realities.
It is an organ of seeing.
Let's deconstruct that idea of seeing, actually, because the author breaks down the word understanding in a way that I found fascinating.
To understand a reality is to literally stand under it.
Is an architectural metaphor almost.
Right, you are not just filing trivia away in a cabinet in your head.
You stand under a perception and you let a shadow fall across you and govern your actions.
Understanding is
bestowed on you, not manufactured.
Yes, it reorganizes a life.
And we have to contrast that direct seeing with reason, the Latin ratio or Greek dianoia.
Reason is inherently indirect.
It is discursive.
Meaning it operates step by step.
Exactly.
It needs to walk the entire path.
It relies on mathematical ratio, comparison, binary logic, you know, this, not that.
It arrives at a mental picture or a formula, not the reality itself.
I don't buy that yet isn't intellect just a fancier word for reason?
Aren't we just splitting hairs over
It is a fair.
Question, but no, we are not splitting hairs.
It is about a hierarchical relationship.
Reason is the instrument the intellect employs, but it is never its rival.
So they do different jobs.
Yes.
Think of it this way.
Reason brings you up to the door.
It defines the outward form.
But the intellect actually walks through the door and experiences the reality directly.
Reason builds the map.
The intellect jumps into the ocean.
And the modern tragedy is that we have collapsed the intellect into the calculating mind.
We pretend the ocean doesn't exist, only the map.
And that collapse fragments us.
I mean, look at what happens.
We take a person's moral bearing and their aesthetic sense of beauty and we shove them into separate rooms away from their intelligence.
We isolate them.
We treat them like they have nothing to do with one another.
But the author talks about the spirit of the intellect, which is this holistic perceiving rooted in the divine breath.
It totally exceeds the mere machinery of the head.
It does.
It encompasses the whole human being.
So having established that the intellect is this faculty of direct vision rather than a calculating machine, the question becomes, what does this look like under extreme pressure?
We have to look at the battlefield to see it.
The author pivots to the chaotic edge of the battle of the camel.
Paint the scene for us because the context is everything here.
You have armies drawn up.
The dust is rising.
The psychological pressure of imminent violence is absolute.
Survival instincts are at their peak.
And suddenly a Bedouin steps from the ranks.
Just a single guy stepping out.
Yes.
And he asks a seemingly absurd, simple question.
Do you say that God is one?
The juxtaposition is just jarring.
You have swords drawn and this man wants to hold a theology seminar and the ranks scold him naturally.
And we have to realize the ranks are operating perfectly on reason.
Because reason assesses the time and the place.
Exactly.
Reason calculates utility.
It says we have a physical threat that theological inquiries can wait.
It is the completely reasonable view.
But the commander of the faithful stops them.
He defends the question.
He tells them to leave the man alone.
He says that this knowledge is exactly what he wishes for the people.
The order of priorities is just profound.
Theology, the right knowledge of ultimate reality is the fundamental intention behind any action.
Whether you are on a prayer rug or a battlefield.
There is no time where asking about the true nature of the divine is out of bounds.
Because the physical conflict is secondary to clarifying that oneness.
So right there on the battlefield, the discourse is given to the young disciple and the ranks.
He delivers the core principle.
That which has no second does not enter the category of number.
That sounds like wordplay.
How does refusing to call God one as a number change anything?
Well, counting is inherently fragile.
The moment you say something is numerically one, you imply a series.
You admit the possibility of 2, 3, 4.
Exactly.
If God is 1 as a number, it implies a series, making the divine just one item among others in the universe.
A thing among things.
Even if it is the most powerful item on the list.
Right.
And that undoes the oneness entirely.
I am thinking of the early Sufi master's definition here.
He defined oneness as setting apart the eternal from all that was originated in time.
Yes.
They share no common measure.
You cannot put them on the same scale.
Which leads us to the dual nature of the real.
It is utterly transcendent, meaning it is inaccessible, it has no likeness.
But simultaneously it is entirely imminent.
To calculating reason that feels like a paradox, but to the intellect it makes sense.
If the real has no second, there is no outside for it to be absent from.
Therefore it must be manifested by all things.
It is impossible to lose.
Because it has no second, the multiplicity of the physical world does not compete with divine oneness.
It declares it.
The trees, the oceans, the dust on the battlefield.
They cease to be opaque facts.
Things become signs pointing home.
But if the physical world is full of signs pointing home, how do we read them?
If I look at a tree with just calculating reason, I just see biology.
We require a guide.
We have to journey from the outward appearance back to the first reality.
Which brings us to the stakes of this deep dive.
The concept of the inner interpretation.
Yes, retracing those appearances.
And that requires engaging with the revealed text.
Quran is described as a silent book inscribed between two covers.
It cannot speak without an interpreter.
And that interpreter is the intellect.
The revealed text requires the intellect to be spoken.
And this science of interpretation has a lineage.
The Prophet, peace, and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family taught it.
And figures like the prophet's cousin inherited it.
Showing that the inner meaning is inexhaustible once the intellect is brought to bear on it.
The ultimate goal being tawhid.
The ultimate making one of truth, leading multiplicity back to the single source.
But we have to steelman the strict rationalist view here.
We should, to be fair to their premise.
The rationalist looks at this and assumes intellect and revelation must exclude each other.
They see it as a zero-sum game.
You are either free and rational or bound and following revelation from the outside.
But if the intellect has this incredible power of direct vision, why rely on a silent text from the outside at all?
Doesn't submitting to revelation just shut down the intellect's freedom?
If you accept the rationalist dichotomy, yes.
But the classical Ismaili traditions reading dismantles that entirely.
In this traditions reading, they do not compete.
They exist in creative reciprocity.
They complete one another.
Exactly.
There is an outer messenger, which is the revelation, and there is an inner messenger, which is the intellect.
There are two reaches of a single act of communication.
The outer messenger speaks and the inner messenger recognizes the voice.
Because they issue from the same source.
So it is recognition, not blind obedience.
But why does the inner intellect perfectly recognize the outer revelation?
Where did they meet before?
Well, they met before this physical world.
Revelation acts as a reminder.
You cannot be reminded of something you never knew.
That makes me think of the primordial testimony from the chapter of The Heights.
Am I not your Lord?
Yes.
The human spirit witnessed the truth before this world, but we are born into a state of spiritual amnesia.
We are distracted by multiplicity.
To understand this, imagine a physician surrounding a man who has lost his memory.
Like a traumatic brain injury.
Exactly.
The man doesn't know who he is.
The physician doesn't force him to memorize a new biography.
He tells the family to bring in familiar tokens from his past.
A watch, a photograph.
Items he used to know.
The tokens don't forcefully insert new memories.
They wake up the dormant mind.
They resonate with what is already sleeping beneath the trauma.
Revelation is that set of tokens.
Okay, I see it now.
I concede that point.
It's not about an external authority forcing a new rule on a blank slate.
It's an alarm clock waking up a truth we already possess but forgot.
It is an awakening.
The truth was already yours.
Which brings us to what feels like the climax of this teaching.
There is a phrase from the collection of Ali's sermons that perfectly anchors this.
He says, the prophets were sent to unearth the buried treasures of the intellect.
To unearth the buried treasures.
The wealth
is already present.
The author elaborates on this with three powerful images.
Let's walk through those.
The first one is the farmer.
The farmer waters a hidden seed.
He doesn't manufacture the life of the plant.
He just provides the water, the revelation, to coax out the life waiting in the dark earth.
And the second is the miner.
Digging for locked gold.
The miner doesn't invent the gold.
He endures the hard labor to bring it up into the light.
The gold was always gold.
And the third is the diver.
Descending to the seabed for pearls.
The pearls are useless in the crushing depth until someone makes the terrifying descent to retrieve them.
In all three, the farmer, the miner, the diver, the work is retrieval.
It is not manufacture.
And that brings us back to the absolute limit of the calculating mind.
Reason is honored for bringing us to the edge.
It gathers the facts.
It brings us to the door.
But it falters before the reality that has no second.
Because reason works by relating one thing to another.
Rumi warned us about this limit.
He said, the leg of the reasoners is a wooden leg, and a wooden leg is exceedingly infirm.
The final step requires the awakened spirit of the intellect.
It requires us to plunge into the ocean.
We have seen how reason fails, how the intellect sees directly, how oneness is beyond number on the battlefield, and how revelation unearths our buried treasures.
That which has no second does not enter the category of number.
So as we wrap up,
I want you to look at your own life.
Which certainties are you currently trying to argue or calculate from the outside using the exhausting mechanics of reason when they might instead be directly seen and remembered from within using the quiet vision of your intellect?
What is 1 habit of attention you can adopt this week that begins to change that approach?
We will leave that hanging in the air for you.